لقد كان الرئيس السابق قد تفوق على الكثير من
الانتقادات التي ذهبت في طريقه للطريقة
التي أرسل بها رسائل حول اللقاحات بالطبع
رفض الحصول على اللقطة الخاصة به علنًا ،
كل هذه الأشياء الليلة الماضية كان
في الواقع في تجمع حاشد في ألاباما
وكان هذا رد فعل الحشد  عندما
قال الرئيس للناس ،
قال الرئيس السابق للناس أن يحصلوا على التطعيم ،
أنا أؤمن تمامًا بحرياتك ،
يجب عليك أن تفعل ما عليك القيام به ،
لكنني أوصي بتناول اللقاحات ، لقد فعلت
ذلك ، من الجيد أخذ اللقاحات ولكنك
لم تحصل على ما يرام  هذا جيد ،
لقد حصلت على
حرياتك لكنني أخذت اللقاح
إذا لم ينجح ، فستكون أول
من يعرف حسنًا ،
أنت تعرف هيذر وكنت
أتحدث قبل العرض لأننا
كنا في فلوريدا فقط ونقول
لا يزال الرئيس ترامب يلوح في الأفق في
فلوريدا ، إنه بالتأكيد قوة رئيسية
لكنه أيضًا
يتناقض نوعًا ما مع ما يقوله رون ديسانتيس
، لذا
سيكون من المثير للاهتمام إلى حد ما أن نرى
كيف  يتلاعب حكيم سواء كان
هذا الاختلاف في الرئيس
ترامب يصر أم لا على أن الأشخاص الذين تعرفهم
يحصلون على التطعيم ، فهذا أمر جيد مقابل
رون ديسانتيس الذي يقول أنك تعلم أن
كل شخص حر في فعل ما
يريد ونوعًا من الضغط أكثر من أجل
حرياته.  سيكون من
المثير للاهتمام معرفة كيفية حدوث ذلك
ومن يأتي في المقدمة في هذا
النقاش